Merry Christmas, coach.
You got me a present. Oh, yeah.
It's tradition. So. Yeah.
A chimney cleaning log.
Now you'll want to burn that every 65 years
or so. Reduces your creosote build up by 70%.
And creosote is what causes chimney fires. So
you'll want to nip that in the bud. Fox.
Kind of reminds me of my late wife, Barb. We
had a Christmas tradition ourselves. My lover
and I would spend Christmas Eve together as
lovers do, and we would make love for hours
in front of the fire.
Well, there you go.
I haven't been. Touched by a lover since my
late wife Barb died.
And I miss the touch of a lover.
To be honest, it's hard to find a good lover.
Well, I'm sure you're fine.
Another person.
Barb was a tremendous lover.
She used to say that the best part about my
body was my legs. To be honest, the best part
about her was her legs, too.
Oh, sounds like she was a wonderful woman.
Big tits, sir.
You never noticed? No. You never noticed
Barb's knocks? No. I would lay her down at
night and I would say. Knock, knock. Who's
there? Big ol boner in my underwear. She
could make an ocean fearing man go boating.
Oh, folks love boating. So.